did you see uh so she had uh an
exemption for medication
for ritalin yes yeah and she's had it
forever yeah she's been taking it since
i guess serena and venus were also
taking it there's something
there's something else that she's
getting that i guess gymnasts get and
it's a case of what they call the
twisties
which is that you know that's vertigo so
a lot of people get it when they go off
ritalin so if you've been on wren for a
long time and get off of it
one of the side effects is vertigo or
loss of balance
really my here's my thing with and if
and obviously
you can't compete if you have vertigo
and all that [ __ ] so yeah but i thought
so this is your favorite
but gymnasts get a sense uh when they do
a lot of uh jumping
that there's this con this thing that's
called um you get you feel like you're
lost in the air so you can't spot
the mission you don't have that she's
the goat so she's dead that's what she
said no that's no
she had the twisty but she said it's
they say it's from
taking berlin for so many years then
going cold turkey one of that things
they can give you vertigo
so obviously you can't do all those
[ __ ] flips in the air because that
makes difference
well i think with that and yeah god
bless her she should definitely not do
it
my thing with that is if she's been
doing within this long
wouldn't ridlen be a form of a
performance enhancer
because it gives you focus yeah so at
that sport wouldn't that be a
performance-enhancing drug
which she has an exemption for well i
guess tokyo believes that right but a
lot of that's why they wouldn't allow
her to do it
yeah and apparently i guess serena and
uh venus
were also on it too yeah a lot of people
i mean you know it's it's
it's it's standard for children uh when
so when kids have adhd or whatever it's
almost the first thing that they
they give you guanfacine which is
something that actually lowers
can it it slows you down they give it to
you at night
it it it slows your heart rate down um
you know
it's more of a sedative rather than
ritalin in the morning yeah riddling
really have you taken i don't know i
don't know i don't know it's actually
adderall but it's like time released
a time release kind of thing is that not
performance enhancing
i i would just because you know the mlb
it's illegal yet but
so many guys take it so so many guys
take it i would say it definitely gets
them focused
as it's help it helps me focus if i take
it it helps me focus now
yeah my own thing is so if again i don't
know i don't know how gymnastics works
here's my other thing i don't give a
[ __ ] about gymnastics but it's
interesting to talk about
but if you can't perform without that
substance
there's a problem right
and that's strange yeah and i don't know
enough about her history where she has
to take it but they had this they asked
the same question when
when somebody was taking beta blockers
okay and beta blockers i think
that's for the heart right well so beta
blockers apparently
get you to calm down it's a little bit
like xanax or something where you won't
so if you have an audition
this guy was a musician and he had to
audition for an orchestra and he was
nervous
yeah and he took beta blockers and they
were like is that a form of performance
enhancing drugs we get into these
questions but that's i mean it's more so
medical right
yeah it is it's a medical exemption yeah
but i mean
beta blockers might be something
different but technically you you can't
even take caffeine
before is that right no caffeine is
illegal is that right it's a performance
you can have you can like drink coffee
all the time
if when you solder i forget the nevada
commissioner come like do you can't have
coffee
in the workout room what a certain
amount of caffeine day of the fight
right no the day and you can never take
adderall
not a shot no but this is a form of
adderall so it helps you focus and
prolongs your energy it's just different
because she's been taking it since she
was a kid
like if you're do does it show up in
tess yeah oh i didn't know that
yeah yeah form a meth bell it's a it's a
it's an amphetamine salt
he's also
i need to be on [ __ ] meth for all i
kids